so the internet went bonkers last Friday
that was the trailer release for Star
Wars Episode 7 the force awakens I
caught it like the second I woke up it
was like 7:15 or something
Pacific time here in California and of
course JJ Abrams is directing this one
people are very excited that it's not in
George Lucas's hands anymore look I
loved the original originals I as I said
in the video that we did last week on
this I I like the prequels not perfect
but I like them but JJ Abrams clearly
already you can see just from that 90
seconds with some pauses just you could
already see the pacing the feel it's
gonna feel more like the originals we're
gonna get a little more there's gonna be
something dark there there's gonna be
something a little more cinematic about
it but one of the things I wanted to
bring up was this thing about the black
stormtrooper because I saw people all
over Twitter we're freaking out about a
black stormtrooper how could there be a
black stormtrooper because the
stormtroopers were all clones of Jango
Fett which that was part of the big
story in the in the prequels now of
course just like what happened in a new
hope the original it could be that that
character was someone that was just in a
stormtrooper uniform but then I saw on
the official at Star Wars account on
Twitter I did not know this but
apparently some people knew this and I
guess maybe this was in some of the
books or something or maybe some of the
offshoot shows that they've done but
that apparently after the Clone Wars so
basically after Revenge of the Sith that
the Empire then shut down the clone
process so then regular people regular
citizens became stormtroopers so that
answers the question we don't need more
everything's racial I know we just did
another video on the racial stuff a
second ago
I know everyone wants to make everything
racial these days and the idea that you
would be upset if there was a black
stormtrooper and not even a good excuse
for it
it's still not really worth getting
upset about it right but the fact that
some people were there is a legitimate
reason for it anyway
that being said just getting that little
that little plot potential plot hole out
of the way I think the thing looks great
I'm excited for it by the way the the
real trailer so that was just the teaser
trailer the real trailer is going to
come out May 1st so we've got about 6
months for that it's going to come out
during Avengers age of Ultron
and I cannot wait for that and may the
force be with you